UR
UTIMEAH?
WELL, WH ASK ABOUT HIM,
AT ARE YOU ASKING ABOUT?ELAS ASY
DAD GET HURT
BUT HE IS.IS SPIRIT?
>>.D WHEN YOU SR DADDY
AGAIN ONE DAY, WHA YO WHEN YOU L
T TOHA
FUN, AND
>> Y
>> WS EVER
WENT TO BED.LWAYS USED T ME
HIM HELPING BRUSH
EETH?
PE THAT THE
WORLD REMEMBERS HIELL, THE D SO
TO HIM. YEAH.
IFTO
YOUR DADDY RIGHT NOW, WHAT WOULD
ITE?
>> IT WOUL,
LOVE YOU.
LL.CIG
TS  FLOYD.YO WE'LL HEAR THE NEE
SPELLIR B LLIAMS.ILAME US YOUFU
DID L , LSLLED GEORGE, NOT ONLY
SPLAYED
N FOR
HEIDU SAW IT.
I SAW IT.
PETHE COUNTRY AND THE GLOBE
WITNESSED ACATE.
WIHEXPD HERE BE  TASKE
GEORGE'S DEATH HAS IMPACTED ME
REST OF OUR LY I R BRAIN AND T
TOE AND CONVEY OISUS IS HUY  FOR
ARTICULATE THE RHTT E ALL THATE
FEE ER THIS , SO PLEASE BEAR
WI
FOR S
BU
EXTENT OF OUPA
BE TEARS WE ARTBREAK A H FAR
EE.LD EVER CRY.RDS SIMPLY CANNO.
BUT NOT NEARLY AINABLE E  BEING
HE WILL HAHE
SEEING HIS FAMILY AGAIN.
WITH THE R.L LURI THAINA WAHEN
SIATHER.
THERE WILL BE NO
CELEBRATIONS.RADUAONGA
THOSE OPPORTUNS PLOU ARE FOREVE
I GERA CHALLENGING TO DO  THESE
.
TRAGIC ANDS TRIAL ANBETWEEN
OUR FAMILY IS FOR BROKENNOT GECY
T OFFA
THAT THE MAX PENTYCRIMR  IMPOSE.
AN BEHALF OF MY , FRIES,
NDUP IS MY SINCEREST
>> YOUR HONOR,PIOK YOU. T
RECORD, THIS WONDERFUL LADY
STANDING HERE IS A HENNE
M ADVOCATE.
>> SHES
ES JUDGE.
NE AND
TEENEACH OFSTEULSPELLING
YOUR NAMES.
F-L-O-Y-D.OYD
>>EAD.
>> I'M HM K.
ON 25, 2020, MY R WAS
>> TAKUR>>ER THAT HAS GUILERATI
IT'S NOT OHAT YOOVER YR AND ,
FEWA
FRHE MAN HIMSELF WHY.
WH THROUOU?
Y --HE K
POHRYMS YOLEAST GEUPU ?
ONE MY BROTHER WAS
WI, AN ANVERSATION, AND AS LOOKO
DATES.
HE WANTED LAN PLAYESWITHTEARTED
UPTHAT C
AND MY D
THIS IS G TO HAVE  TO
HERE, THAT I HAVE TO TALDAUGHTE,
OUT R
EAI'M HERE ON BEHALF FAMILOF M.
YOUR ME O
T ALREADY. WANT SL.
AWE'VE BEEN THROUGH THAT Y,
SMACKEONNO,
NOBECAUSE IF IS USREE
WODNENPE'DL.